erstes thema
was gerade los ist
gar nichts
das ist ja irgendwie das ding ich habe
seit sieben wochen ein video hier auf
meinem youtube hauptkanal hochgeladen
und ich denke alle die hier gerade zu
schauen fragen sich jetzt warum
ich das fragt sich niemand wir uns jetzt
natürlich wie jeder andere youtuber
machen und erstmals minuten um heißen
brei herum lagern von wegen ich hab so
einen stress man so viele projekte ich
habe so viel in der pipeline so viel ist
geplant aber ich bin einfach schwanger
viel spaß beiseite freunde ich bin ganz
ehrlich zu euch ich will hier schnell
wie möglich auf den punkt kommen und den
gibt es nicht
es gibt keinen grund warum ich dieses
hochgeladen haben die frage stelle ich
mir auch seit wochen warum mache ich
eigentlich nichts ich habe in den
letzten sieben wochen nahezu daily
videos auf 1 2 kanal gebracht der
podcast de kultur von sandra mir haben
ganz normal wöchentlich online ich habe
tik tok hochgeladen und sogar einen
instagram bild ich war aktiv
nur nicht hier
und ich weiß mich warum im grunde zu
schreiben eigentlich hatte bock auf
videos machen ich habe unmengen an die
ideen was sich hochladen will und auch
von den zahlen her lief alles exorbitant
super also es gab schlichtweg keinen
grund warum mich einfach plötzlich zwei
monate nichts hochgeladen habe vor allem
weil auch privat alles perfekt ist ich
kann mich wirklich in keinster weise
gerade aktuell war irgendetwas
beschweren trotzdem habe ich nichts
hochgeladen da er jetzt hier ganz kurz
die ihnen von meiner lieben freunde ab
heute komme wieder videos
ja ich werde in nächster zeit erst mal
nicht täglich hochladen also es kommt
keine daddy applaus die werden auf einem
zweig luchsen kommen dann könnt ihr
gerne abonnieren da kommen reactions da
kommt gaming da kommen kleine lustige
videos also wirklich alles möglich das
schwachsinn und das ist extrem gut weil
da nimmt mir ein kollege von mir aus
hamburg die arbeit ab und schneidet die
videos für mich auch mal überhaupt kanal
hier werde allerdings auch in zukunft
weiterhin ich die videos schneiden
mein beileid schirrmann euch nächsten
videos die ich auf dem kanal geplant
sind sind eine doktor bieber challenge
die tage dann habe ich fußball gespielt
gegen sandra zum ersten mal so richtig
in der halle und so was alles ist jetzt
ja geil es kommt bewertete er video es
kommt ein neues minecraft projekt
ein kleines
minecraft mit lukas staffel 3 kommt
irgendwann im herbst oder so da hab ich
was richtig riesiges geplant und länger
will ich euch ehrlich gesagt doch gar
nicht nerven
ich habe euch lieb
dass ich euch jetzt keine antwort geben
konnte warum ich weg war habe ich bin
wieder da
respekt